inciso se encuentra todas las
coordenadas x que sean puntos de
inflexión de la función f justifica tu
respuesta así que vamos a hablar de
puntos de inflexión un punto
es de inflexión
inflexión cuando cambiamos la concavidad
es decir cuando cambiamos
de una concavidad hacia arriba
hacia arriba
a una concavidad de hacia abajo
hacia abajo
es decir cuando cambiamos una concavidad
hacia arriba a una concavidad hacia
abajo tenemos un punto de inflexión o al
revés o viceversa
cuando cambiamos de una concavidad hacia
abajo a una concavidad hacia arriba y
esto pasa si y sólo si si y sólo si la
segunda derivada cambia de ser positiva
a negativa
la segunda derivada cambia de positiva
a negativa en el caso en el que tengamos
un cambio de la concavidad hacia arriba
a la concavidad hacia abajo o viceversa
en el otro caso y bueno esto pasa si
solos y si y sólo si y donde podemos ver
el cambio de signo en la segunda
derivada bueno esto será cierto si sólo
si la primera derivada que pasa con ella
bueno si la primera derivada cambia de
crecer a decrecer
o viceversa
y viceversa
he usado muchas veces esta palabra
viceversa en este ejercicio así que
bueno qué te parece si pensamos en f
prima de x porque es la gráfica que
tenemos entonces donde f prima van de
crecer a decrecer o viceversa porque
también podríamos ir desde crecer a
crecer así que vamos a pensar de un poco
si observas por aquí efe va decreciendo
decreciendo decreciendo decreciendo y de
repente cambia y empieza a crecer a
crecer a crecer entonces aquí justo aquí
tenemos un punto de inflexión justo aquí
en x igual a menos 1 observa aquí
tenemos la pendiente de la derivada de x
igual a 0
efe mi prima de x igual a 0 y bueno eso
es porque f prima sabemos que es
diferenciable la función f es dos veces
derivable en este intervalo entonces
podemos pensar en que la derivada de la
derivada de x
va a ser igual a 0 justo en este punto y
existe otro más
bueno aquí efe empieza a crecer a crecer
a crecer a crecer a crecer y en este
punto cambia y empieza a decrecer de
crecer de crecer de crecer entonces este
también va a ser un punto de inflexión
en x igual a uno observa tenemos que la
pendiente de la recta tangente a la
curva f prima de x en ese punto también
vale cero y después de crecemos y
crecemos de crecemos de crecemos y en
este punto empezamos a crecer a crecer a
crecer a crecer en x igual a 3 así que
en este punto de aquí tenemos otro punto
de inflexión por lo tanto tenemos tres
puntos de inflexión esto pasa en x igual
a menos 1 en x igual a 1 y en x igual a
3 estos tres son los puntos en donde
podemos ver que la función de crecen y
cambian a crecer aquí crecen y cambia a
decrecer y aquí otra vez de crece y
cambia a crecer estos son los tres
puntos
así que si regresamos por acá puedo
decir que mi respuesta va a ser que
déjame escribirlo así esto pasa
esto
pasa
en dónde
x igual a menos 1 coma en x igual a 1 y
en x igual a 3 estos son mis puntos de
inflexión porque nuestra gráfica f prima
cambia de crecer a decrecer o viceversa